[Música]
vamos con nuestra revista de prensa de
la mano de Rosa Pérez más de buenos días
para usted Rosa Buenos días Ángela vamos
a hablar de Ucrania básicamente no el
New York Times se ha titulado un
artículo que dice Rusia liberó a ciertos
prisioneros para luchar su guerra Así es
como les fue a algunos hablemos de este
tema Exacto es un reportaje en
profundidad que vamos a detallar a lo
largo de esta Crónica firmado por
Anthony curmanae Alina la oficina y a
katherina Body allina y recapitulemos
demos un poco de contexto recordemos que
hacia el mes de julio de 2000 a 22 el
líder del grupo de mercenarios de
mercenarios Wagner hablamos de Jenni
prisgoring se empezó a pasear Por las
aprisiones de Rusia para intentar
reclutar a personas que estuvieran
cumpliendo condena para que se unieran a
las filas del grupo Wagner para combatir
en Ucrania que les prometía a cambio
bien un salario de unos a 1700 a dólares
al mes una indemnización en de muerte en
combate de unos 80.000 Dólares pero
sobre todo la Libertad en forma de
indulto presidencial si sobreviven o
sobrevivían al contrato de seis meses de
lucha en Ucrania ahora bien si
desertaban consumían drogas mantenían
relaciones sexuales serían ejecutados y
una de las tesis de este artículo es
precisamente que ahora empiezan a
expirar estos contratos que empezaron en
julio no seis meses después y que pasado
este periodo los que han logrado
sobrevivir a estos contratos y regresan
a la vida civil en Rusia lo hacen por un
lado sin haber cumplido su pena de
prisión lo que tampoco es garantía sin
embargo no de ningún tipo de reinserción
y también acarreando más traumas
relacionados con la guerra precisamente
y anaquelmel quien es abogada por los
derechos de los prisioneros en Rusia y
que trabaja con personas que se han
alistado con el grupo de mercenarios
Wagner dice son personas
psicológicamente rotas que regresan con
un sentido del deber cumplido la
creencia de han matado para defender la
patria y son personas que pueden ser muy
peligrosas Y es que la mayoría de los
hombres que se alistaron al grupo Wagner
no a cambio de libertad estaban
cumpliendo condena por delitos menores
sin embargo también había según las
fuentes de este artículo que estaban
condenados por delitos de violación o de
asesinato Rosa De cuántas personas
estaríamos hablando que habrían podido
salir de la cárcel para unirse y
combatir con el grupo Wagner Pues según
este artículo habría unos 400.000
prisioneros en Rusia de los cuales
40.000 aproximadamente se habrían
alistado al grupo de mercenarios Wagner
y de los cuales de estos cuarenta mil
unos 30.000 habrían muerto desertado o
resultado heridos sin embargo la cifra
no puede ser verificada de forma
independiente son cifras filtradas por
la inteligencia occidental porque no hay
una lista pública Y es que de hecho es
ilegal en Rusia reclutar a mercenarios
No de hecho el grupo Wagner negaba su
propia exi hasta hace un año tal y como
dice este texto sobre el papel los
prisioneros nunca fueron a la guerra
sino trasladados a prisiones cercanas a
la frontera con Ucrania y este texto
señala el caso de Anastasia que no da su
apellido que dice que cuando preguntó
sobre el paradero de su familiar a la
prisión donde estaba cumpliendo condena
los guardas apenas le dijeron que su
familiar no estaba disponible mire sin
embargo qué es lo que dicen los
testimonios de los hombres que sí han
ido a luchar con Wagner en Ucrania
encontramos por ejemplo el caso de
andrey fedev que estaba condenado por
robo y que tenía experiencia militar por
ejemplo debido a esta experiencia ya en
combate en el ejército lo pusieron a
cargo de un destacamiento de prisioneros
enviados a mahmud él dice nos dijeron
sigue adelante hasta que te maten sin
embargo lo cuentan los periodistas del
New York Times por teléfono desde
Noruega después del desertar en
noviembre Pero es que recordemos que
desertar es una opción muy arriesgada
como decíamos Y es que el líder del
grupo Wagner en un discurso publicado de
septiembre dijo No Hay posibilidad de
volver a la prisión los que lleguen ahí
y digan creo que estoy en el lugar
equivocado ahí en Ucrania en combate
Serán marcados como desertores y
fusilados y el texto señala que
prisgorín el líder del grupo Wagner es
ex recluso y entendió perfectamente la
cultura de la prisión y combinó
hábilmente La amenaza de castigo con la
promesa de una vida nueva y digna
finalmente hay pruebas de los perdones
que están recibiendo los que ya
cumplieron con este contrato Pues esta
es la cuestión más compleja Ángela
porque más o menos así hay ciertas
pruebas Y es que para revertir la caída
de los alistamientos que se suma a que
en los próximos meses van a continuar
expirando cada vez más contratos Wagner
publicita las recompensas que está dando
a los ex prisioneros que ya han cumplido
supuestamente con estos seis meses de
contratos y publica distintos vídeos no
en un vídeo particularmente prisgoring
dice necesitaba su talento criminal para
matar al enemigo en la guerra en Ucrania
los que quieran volver a la guerra aquí
estamos esperándolos los que quieran
casarse estudiar adelante bendiciones no
y en estos vídeos los prisioneros
reciben papeles descritos como el perdón
o la anulación de la condena sin embargo
ninguno de estos papeles se ha hecho
público y de digamos según de hecho
según la Constitución rusa solo Putin
puede conceder un indulto y el crimen no
ha publicado de momento estos decretos
sin embargo dimitripescoff recientemente
señaló que hay decretos con más o menos
grado de secretismo y que todos está
haciendo de acuerdo con la ley en todo
caso nunca se habrían emitido perdones a
tal escala y simplemente este artículo
para terminar acaba con la cita de un
hombre de apellido y asterov que tras
tres semanas en casa se prepara para
regresar al frente que dice quiero
defender mi patria me gustaba todo allí
la vida civil es aburrida Rosa gracias a
usted y continuamos con nuestra
programación